[Music]
your hands are really dexterous things
we use them everyday for all sorts of
tasks to make the best use we possibly
can of that is to build a puppet around
the hand so knuckles become knees or
elbows by the end of the day it's all
the illusion of movement my name is
Barnaby Dixon I'm a puppeteer alright
I'm 26 years old and I started making
puppets two years ago this is dad chick
this is the first puppet I ever made
this is Manu and it takes two hands to
operate this puppet and this is the
dinosaur I think this is the most
expressive puppet that I have I make
them in my room really
each of these puppets represents maybe
two months work and it's a process
that's driven completely by
trial-and-error the materials to make
these puppets I usually can just get
them online raw bits of metal or
plumber's epoxy just things like that
really listen here I made the puppets
virtually with the purpose to create
video content on YouTube most weeks I'll
take data check out for an outing where
I'll film it ah the great British
seaside software - sand oh joy of joys I
always do try and make them funny
the proud URI of the waves thundering -
oh boy I do get self-conscious about
having the puppet sound about
some people just think I'm an adult
playing with a toy people kind of don't
know what to think of it full novalis
maybe Barnaby I love so recently I was
on a German talent show that was about
puppies who was caught dip whooping
stars
[Music]
and I ended up winning this it was very
validating and so I think yeah a lot of
people would think it's quite a weird
thing for a 26 year old to be in his
bedroom making puppets but it's working
out for me so ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]